[Musik]
du bist nicht
hallo herr pfarrer sell it welt heute
geht es ein richtig tolles und vor allem
sehr leckere prozent ich werde nämlich
einfach selber machen und zwar sieht es
aber so aus ich habe hier ein richtig
fruchtiges joghurteis mit aprikosen mit
dabei richtig cremig das ganze in einer
knackigen weiße schokoladen füller und
mandeln drauf super einfach und vor
allem super lecker jetzt einmal in der
eis am stiel form gemacht und einmal und
sieht auch richtig raffiniert auf ihn so
klein und sie mit grün förmchen
das sei eigentlich aber später wie
dieses festival wird weil meine rente
verwaltung und ein schönes dabei
rausgekommen und richtig teure kette
autoradio fahren darf und wo nicht aus
dem topf aus der fällige verpackung
etwas raus reihe soll was sie selber
macht und so richtig cool ja dazu sagen
das eis ist ohnehin so sieht's aus ein
bisserl marmoriert hier sieht man dass
cremiger joghurt eis das fruchtige
aprikosen eis vorher sind auch ziemlich
kalorienarm muss ich sagen
in der weißen kuratorisch ich natürlich
nichts mehr aber dennoch muss ich sagen
viel gesünder und viel viel leckerer als
klein ich gekauft beweist und viel
weniger zu groß und viel viel weniger
druck also eigentlich kaum zucker drin
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten das iphone mit gestern schon
vorbereitet damit über nacht gefrieren
konnte und heute hatte ich fertig
gestellt und hier vorne stehen die
zutaten für das einst brauch ich 600
gramm aprikosen zwei esslöffeln honig
500 gramm joghurt zwei esslöffel butter
zucker einen teelöffel vanille extrakt
und den abriss von einer unbehandelten
zitrone zuerst startet jetzt mit den
aprikosen ihr könnt natürlich auch
anderes obst verwenden
aber die sind wirklich super lecker vor
allem fest die werde ich jetzt passiert
und den stein herausnehmen
[Musik]
hiermit die aprikosen in eine pfanne
machen als man nur die hälfte
und wenn es da drinnen wissing
karamellisieren lassen aber ein bisschen
anbraten und gebt dann gleich den honig
mit aktien aber erst mal bekomme den
listen farbe
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der honig das tor
und dann darf das ganze im sitzen kochen
und dann nehme ich die eine büffeln hier
raus und macht das gleiche auch bei dass
zweiten traktion und in der zwischenzeit
können wir dann schon mal den logos
vorbereiten
jetzt nehme ich den joghurt davon 500
gramm unternehme ich gern den ga sie
zehn prozent der ist nämlich super
cremig und vor allem wie ihr sehen könnt
auch stichfest das heißt es wird auch
später super cremig denn auch eine ganz
ganz milde säure passt also
geschmacklich wirklich sehr zu herzen
aber auch im süden gerichtet dann kommt
hier der puderzucker mit dazu hier könnt
ihr wenn ihr möchtet auch honig
verwenden etwas vanille extrakt und den
abrieb der zitrone
[Musik]
jetzt einfach mit einem schneebesen
krebs führen
die erste position karamellisieren
wie fühle ich jetzt direkt in ein hohes
gefäß denn die aprikosen werden gleich
kuriert jetzt können die aprikosen
püriert werden darf in dem kleinstaat
mit
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr gerne die
aprikosen mit etwas zitronensaft
beträufeln fast geschmacklich wirklich
super dass du unser möchte gibt auch ein
bisschen zitronensaft mit dem joghurt
jetzt muss die aprikosen mache etwas
abkühlen bevor sie in die form kommt
raffel assistiert abgedeckt stehen und
dann geht's gleich weiter wie joghurt
füllung für mich jetzt hier in einem
spritzbeutel ein ihr könnte zum beispiel
auch einen gefrierbeutel nehmen denn
sollte sich ein bisschen einfacher die
einstampfen gleich zurück aber es können
auch jochen lassen dementiert auch aber
da ich mit dem klettern werde
[Musik]
beutel verschließe ich jetzt mit einem
gummiband und jetzt schneidet unten
jeweils einer spitze weg und jetzt kann
sie immer ein bisschen von der joghurt
creme und von der aprikosen film
abwechselnd in diese förmchen rein
schlichten das eis am stiel förmchen
falls ihr diese nicht habt könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch eine große kastenform
nehmen und einfach ein großes problem
machen und es auch im orient mit
rheinfelden
[Musik]
und dann können wir so holz später
nehmen und die eltern noch inzwischen
reindrücken lässt es ganz kurz ins
gefrierfach und zeigt euch was ich mit
dem geld mache
wie gesagt keine ice formen habt dann
könnt ihr auch eine kastenform nehmen
entweder eine backform oder zum beispiel
eine plattform die solltet ihr aber
vorher mit frischhaltefolie auslegen
damit es später wieder rauskommt oder
ihn nimmt ganz einfach nur telefon
plattform zum backen verwendet nicht so
gerne aber es ist ein wirklich ideal
das heißt hier kann man sie auch
wunderbar einführen und dann einfrieren
und es sollte dann mindestens für vier
bis sechs stunden aber besser über nacht
eingefroren werden
[Musik]
ich hatte bereits über nach dem
gefrierschrank geht es richtig gut fest
und ich habe jetzt hier schon mal 300
gramm weiße kuvertüre geschmolzen und
zwar in einem warmen aber nicht
kochenden wasser war und dann habe ich
die kuvertüre mit etwas kokosfett
verfeinern wo es einfach mit dem
flüssiger und glänzt auch schön und
jetzt einfach in ein hohes trinkgefäß
reihen gegeben also in ein trinkglas
denn da kann ich sie am besten eindruck
jetzt könnt ihr die eisbahn zum
rausnehmen entweder kurz in der hand ein
bisschen wärme damit sie rauskommen oder
einfach kurz so unter fließendes wasser
halten denn erstens wird dann hier ein
gepunktetes komplett verschlossen am
tropf abtropfen lassen
dann gebe ich damals gestiftete man
darüber dass die kuvertüre jetzt hier im
warmen wasser stehen
er hat ist aus einfach deswegen weil es
so kalt ist und die kuvertüre ansonsten
einfach zu schnell hart wird dann
abtropfen mit jetzt ganz schnell sein
denn die schokolade wird fest jetzt
machen wir das ganze büro kurz abtropfen
und dann hier drüben einmal drauflegen
dann halte ich einfach kurz- bis die
schokolade fest ist und kennst dann
ablegen
[Musik]
das gefrorene eis habe ich jetzt auch
silikonform raus gedrückt und dann die
restliche kurzführer rein gegossen und
es einfach wieder rein gewinnt und nach
dem gefrieren hat man dann so wie hier
eine richtig tolle glänzen geschickt im
prinzip hat sich jetzt die
resteverwertung zieht aber wirklich
super hübsch aus dafür sind silikon form
auch echt gut aber drin backen tue ich
nicht so gerne
außerdem plane die verzinse echtrop und
vor allem die tolle das beste bewertung
der risiken ist immer so wenn sie auf
rund zwei jahren zusammen
deswegen ist wenn man mit silikon form
arbeitet so was tut dann ist kein
problem
ja und jetzt sagen hier dass am stehend
hier einmal ohne das ist für 11
ich hab da einfach die mandeln dann
weggelassen weil er dann kritisiert
frucht eis zu essen ohne dass sie sich
daran verschluckt ich will hören
nein ein joghurt mit aprikose und
außenraum die mandeln wandel dafür ist
ein insider wissen dass magna und liebe
man jetzt darf stuhl leider nicht
probieren sondern heute darf der oper
bands probieren im berner oberland ist
aus ihrem dorf und zwar ist der papa von
der kabine und im schach und packt unter
anderem auch die pakete der pakete und
wenn ja vor allem auf als richtig
erweisen
die werden richtig gepackt hat ein
bisschen die augen des wege- und
vertraute auf dem neuen paket wenig
beschwerden bei opa werden anrufe und
nachfrage
daran kommt auch die die fruchtige
schlicht dabei die oberfläche ist hier
ein problem ist zwar immer gemein aber
was sonst mit gerti kinder vor allem in
afrika oder das wort aprikose wahnsinn
und diese version zusätzlich trainiert
deswegen 10% joghurt macht richtig
cremig ihr könnt zwar auch einen joghurt
mit weniger fett nehmen aber das wetter
hat nicht dollar kam
engmann wagen und begeistert ich denke
das werde ich im nächsten jahr zur
erdbeerzeit auch noch mit erdbeer machen
und wahrscheinlich wünscht ihr euch
jetzt weitere eis am stiel rezepte
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
falls ihr euch zum beispiel auch mal ein
richtig leckeres magnum als mönch wobei
ich sagen muss ich nicht besser als wenn
also schon so mein favorit wir suchen
sie fragen ja ja ich meine welt ist eben
so lange weil wir haben ganz viele
hungrige dieses probieren möchten aber
ansonsten würde ich sagen dass zwei
wochen im gefrierfach auf jeden fall
und dann kann man schnell wieder neues
machen also allein mit dem bericht auf
jedoch auf jeden fall auf jedem
geburtstag vor allem kinder geboten weil
das rezept nachmachen wolf geht auch
tennis welt das steht doch mal ganz
genau und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß dabei irgendwie nächsten mal jemand
größer
unser shop
[Musik]
[Gelächter]